when you put the earth in a globe right
on a ball it has a beginning and an end
point that's it say that's not the end
of it say there there were land masses
found beyond what we're told is the end
pull of the earth good yeah well Matt
yeah I'm Carla nice to meet you nice to
meet you too Cheers
[Music]
a man actually went traveled to try and
find the actual telemetry data of the
moon landing happening right
unfortunately seven hundred boxes of
magnetic tapes telemetry data is gone
there's they have no idea where it is
actually it's very very hard to keep
magnetic tape you're not trying to
seriously say Led Zeppelin didn't record
Led Zep one because that tape no longer
exists anymore
we're literally talking about supposedly
one of the greatest ever feats of
mankind let up now migrate literally the
greatest feats of mankind man first
walking on the moon though state that
it's not that they're saying these tapes
rotted away these tapes were damaged
we couldn't they don't know where they
all were never they did as if they never
exists 700 boxes of tapes I mean you
could call it an anomaly if you want to
mate out it's not right but it's not
evidence if someone comes in and says
I've seen a ferry in my garden all right
yeah I don't have to look under every
single blade of grass to say that there
wasn't a ferry in the gut right yeah
because your claim is so outlandish but
what I would argue is that what is
outlandish is saying that in the 1960s
you put men into a metal rocket and you
shot them through a near-perfect vacuum
250,000 miles away they landed safely on
a rock 250,000 miles away and then came
back and then we just didn't go back
that claim is outlandish that was
actually predicted so if you go back to
the there was a some papers by a by
arthur c clarke and he predicted that
mankind would try it and that we would
go there a couple of times we would not
do it very often because it was just
economically unviable
[Music]
yeah you would say there were anomalies
right you would say it's a basis of
anomalies but I would say that basically
everything that the majority of what
NASA produced sorry it's fiction III
find it very difficult to understand
what the motivation for NASA just to be
just a complete be a sort of enormous
lying machine when you put the earth in
a globe right on a ball it has a
beginning and an end point that's it
once you go past a certain point you
just end up on the other side right but
say that's not the end of it say there
there were land masses found beyond what
we're told is the end pull of the earth
you don't want to keep those public
notes because there's resources here
that can be taken advantage of by people
in high positions of power what do you
do but who are these people in these
high positions of power because we've
had generations since then and what
about what the Russians and the Chinese
and I think this south and the North
Koreans and the South Koreans the
Australians and I would say what they do
at any point I would say when it gets to
a certain point they're all involved a
China China's all these space sub
agencies every single one of these space
agencies are doing the same thing in
fact if you look at China's work it is
some of the worst faking of space that's
ever happened you you you you look at
what they're producing and saying is
real space travel and it's people in
pools that they're not in space you can
see bubbles coming out of their helmets
it's a joke
[Music]
flat is probably the most the most
probable we can approve motion without
motion none of it works and second
obviously being a major one is that we
can't detect curvature the globe models
a little bit problematic there's plenty
of experiments that show the curvature
of the earth I happen to live by the
coast I've got a really expansive view
out onto the Atlantic and I can see the
ships and I can see them dip down over
the horizon so I've physically seen the
curvature for myself right
you could you could also get into a high
altitude jet and actually physically see
the curvature of the earth pilots see it
all the time a lot of physicists will
completely disagree with you do you
remember when Felix Baumgartner did the
jump yeah the Red Bull jumper and he'll
tell you he'll be the first to tell you
that they were using a fisheye lens in
the camera because from his altitude it
would have been impossible to see
curvature and I agree with you if you're
in a jet or a bomber you may see a curve
to the earth when you're high however
that's because you're in glass shaped
like this plenty of pilots who fly
passenger jets who will tell you that
it's it's it's flat the whole way around
as they seize hard-won scientific
knowledge that you just can't just put
in the beam because you've read a couple
of websites or you've seen a couple of
experiments certainly and you've read
things that aren't necessarily by the
consensus of scientists scientific
skepticism has to take an evidence-based
approach and I think this is where you
could bring in something like Occam's
razor is say what of these two different
things requires us to have the least
amount of assumptions stationary and
flat versus globular and moving yeah
right I'm looking around I feel like I'm
standing still I don't feel like
anything is moving so the least amount
of assumptions in my yeah based on
Occam's razor is that I am still
[Music]
Newton's laws they've been unbelievably
successful in describing the world and
and predicting things and bringing us
new technology it's not that they're
wrong that just not fully described you
think of knowledge as being this big
building up of a pyramid of knowledge
Europe you never achieve the truth
you're just adding layer upon layer as
you get nearer nearer and nearer and
nearer the truth right well well Newton
was categorically wrong I admire your
optimism however I don't feel like those
gaps will ever be filled I don't think
the pyramid to the truth will ever be
finished you don't trust the bottom
layers and and therefore anything that
you see you're almost having to start
from scratch know what you see which is
essentially why you almost have a a you
know a a B C style knowledge of things
like flat earth because you're going
right back to the big beginning anymore
okay because up until NASA was founded
in we were shown so those so-called
proof this this argument is never died
we the Flat Earth has been a a contender
in this argument we know it's been
fringe for two and a half thousand years
no it has both probably skeptics but my
form of skepticism is a scientific
skepticism I would actually disagree and
say that my form of skepticism is a
scientific skepticism because it follows
the scientific method natural science
one of my favorite physicists ever was
Richard Fineman and he describes science
in an in in a fantastic way he said the
steps of Sciences that we observe then
we guess that's it is it yes we use
nature and experimentation to either
verify or nullify that guess if it
disagrees with experiment it's wrong
that's that's it that's what Richard
Fineman said no I don't agree rich rich
a fireman hero is mark he's absolutely
my hair I've just finished
surely you're joking mr. fine okay he
understands that this that science is
this building up slowly of knowledge to
be honest he would be horrified at your
take on science particularly hate
particularly how you just put it there
because it's not quite right he is a
fantastic
advocate of science and he would I would
of course be horrified by Flat Earth he
genuinely would anytime I talk about
something controversial they will make
sure that they've put an article under
my video to say what the opposite of
what I'm saying is true why would you
need to censor this kind of information
if it's so clearly wrong let's face it
if we were talking about a much more
offensive idea if we if we look at an
example would you be happy with a like
not at YouTube down playing Nancy video
it's a different well I think we're
talking about something completely
different when we're talking about you
know it's someone promoting Nazism
someone promoting hate towards a group
of people whereas when we're discussing
things I flat it we're discussing ideas
you know what I do agree with the aisle
I am gonna shift it a little bit over
here because because the freedom of
speech I think is really important
[Music]
my god see okay I would say this because
I would actually say that everybody is
brainwashed to a degree I would say that
I brainwashed to Italy most of the time
we exist in some form of an echo chamber
whether we want to or not what you
should be trying to do is be very very
open minded but not so open minded that
your brains fall out I mean that that's
kind of it and and as a scientist you
want people to come along and disprove
your theater I think I'm sure not not
even just challenge your theories but to
disprove them I think that that's the
most exciting thing in science you may
have belonged to a tribe but I don't
think you've been brainwashed by that
tribe I just think that you've rejected
what I would call normal science and
you're going for something else that's
that's not actually science yeah yeah
yeah why not it's like a good
conversation I think absolutely oh yeah
as you should always test your ideas
about someone else it's like I see as
you as a person and I'm sure we'd have
some a great time out and like enjoy
each other's company sure cheers Cheers
there's a lot of geniuses in marvel year
Batman won't beat them with rap time
with we're talking with prep time he
wouldn't read them he won't be there
with prep time Bruce Wayne will take out
God himself
okay God Himself God himself yeah